hey guys it is Friday again which means
I got five of this week's best stories
and gaming all ready to go for you kids
the good stuff the division may have
been delayed until 2016 but it's not the
lack of people working on it
since there are now four different
Ubisoft Studios developing game this
week Ubisoft annecy has joined massive
Red Storm and reflections they were
already contributing to the game annecy
originally worked on Rayman 2 as well as
Splinter Cell Pandora tomorrow and
Assassin's Creed 2 of multiplayer mode
the plan is for them to contribute their
prior experience with multiplayer online
games to the divisions development and
hopefully with all that manpower will
actually get to see it early next year
like the Ubisoft have suggested parsec
RPG grandia 2 is pretty damn popular
back in the day and now it's on its way
to Spain go home Online Entertainment
America said they received enthusiastic
feedback for the creation of a remaster
after a survey conducted in April and
decided to bring the game to Tuesday the
game will also have mouse and keyboard
and gamepad support as well as steam
achievements and trading card gung-ho
America president Joanne it was Saki
said quote Grandia 2 was chosen for a PC
re-released because it represents both a
hallmark of the grandest series and an
example of how great JRPGs can be the
game is best known for its innovative
battle system
this weekend cheap things Xbox Live is
unveil their latest deals with gold
discounted games include Destiny's
thanks ro gat out of hell and saints row
floor for Xbox one if you have an Xbox
360 you can still get destiny and saints
row chief but you'll also be able to get
a load of Gears of War judgment DLC
packs for Less as well as saints row the
third these deals are all good until May
18 the Xbox one is officially the
best-selling console in April according
to the NPD s latest figures Sony's ps4
took out the top spot in March but the
tables have turned for last month
Microsoft VP of Marketing Mike Nichols
said quote Xbox one console sales in the
u.s. increased 63 percent in April 2015
compared to April 2014 and Xbox Live
comparisons showed the number of active
global users for Xbox one and Xbox 360
per 24 percent Sony still hold their own
however selling more software for ps4
than Microsoft did for Xbox one in the
month of April and it remains the number
one console in overall sales
survival games have become something of
a mesh hit as now there's one with a
crapload of dinosaurs in it developer
wild-card Studios announced open-world
dinosaur game Ark survival evolved this
week the game is currently in
development for PC Xbox one and ps4 and
it's slated to come to early access in
June the studio says they've been
inspired by dinosaur movies like The
Land Before Time diner topia and
Jurassic Park
they said they hope the game would be
quote one of the most ambitious hardcore
large-scale survival experiences ever
devised let me know down in the comments
whether or not you think dinosaurs could
be the next craze in gaming and if
you're on board with that this week on
site I tell you all about great games
based on books on the chest top GTA 5
mods returns and Lucy goes over the
worst season passes those are all the
things that I have been from this week
but as always let me know what mattered
to you and I'll catch you again on
Monday